[Music]
all right so let's talk about the
Natural Sciences versus the social
sciences first for the layman what is
the difference they both have science in
a gag come on
right so the late the layperson will
often use these sort of simplifying
heuristics to determine what is science
versus not if you're wearing a lab coat
if you have a completely different right
if you have a couple of chemical
formulas that's science because of the
average layperson that's impenetrable on
the other hand most people have for
example a folk psychology they have an
innate sense of what psychology is and
therefore to the extent that they feel
that they could contribute even though
they might be laypeople somehow that's
less impenetrable to them right so they
then will create this false dichotomy
where chemistry and physics that's real
science but sociology you know it's for
people who couldn't hack it in physics
the reality is that the only difference
is what are the phenomena that you're
studying across these two general
rubrics of science in the social
sciences you're studying psychology
anthropology economics sociology it
could be as rigorous as the Natural
Sciences so let me give you an example
if you could if you're a sociologist you
could study social metree which is you
know for example how this power diffuse
within a network and you could use very
fancy mathematics graph theory to try to
understand this so the type of
mathematical modeling that you would use
to study how power diffuses within a
network is actually a very fancy
mathematical approach but sociology has
somehow been co-opted by the activists
right yeah so we then view it as being
less scientific but sciences simply
means adhering truthfully to the
scientific method I posit a hypothesis I
think about the data that I would need
to collect that would either falsify or
not hypothesis I collect that data I
apply some sort of statistical analysis
some mathematical analysis to analyze
the data and then I go one way or the
other that could be just as applied if
it's an economics or if it is in physics
so it is wrong that often
letters and emails from people asking me
what a psychology really a science and
of course it's a life really well
ultimately what is more laudable than
studying the most important organism
that we know called humans right yeah so
so it's not as though by the sheer
nature of what physicists study they are
real scientists but the sociologists is
not and by the way I'm not trying to
defend sociologists here because I often
I'm the one who's criticizing since I
usually I'm criticizing them for
deviating from the scientific method
what makes them less scientist is that
they become activists and not scientist
but you could be just as much as a
scientist if you study something in
business or if you study something in
chemistry yeah it's interesting that you
talk about activists not scientists
because that's what I've been saying
about journalists these people are not
doing true journalism and fact-finding
any more in reporting nice and based on
evidence what they're doing is letting
their own biases slam right into the
middle of anything and so far so one of
the things that I will say
differentiates the science the Natural
Sciences from the social sciences and
that's very much at the heart of the
work that I do the Natural Sciences have
organized trees of knowledge so in
physics people agree on a set of core
knowledge that at this point has become
unassailable notwithstanding the fact
that they still have the epistemic
humility to say oh if new provision it's
only provisional if something now
falsified it I'm willing to revise it
right there is but the bedrock the
bedrock there there's core knowledge
that is now unassailable in physics and
chemistry there aren't chemists who are
for the periodic table at Kennesaw are
against the Reg right therefore you
could build coherent trees of knowledge
or the term that I love to use which was
reintroduced into the common lexicon by
EO Wilson the evolution biologist at
Harvard is conciliate unity of knowledge
so the Natural Sciences by the by the
nature of how they test theories have
these organized trees of knowledge
that's what's lacking in the social
sciences and the reason it's lacking is
not because the social sciences are any
less scientific it's because it is easy
for ideologies to creep into the social
sciences right so if I'm a libertarian
or a Marxist I might study economics in
a way that is very polluted by my
personal ideology so it's not that the
social sciences are epithermal logically
any inherently less scientific than
chemistry is that biases are easier to
creep in yeah
it's funny to live out here and I talk
to sometimes someone's a leftist
economist or libertarian accountants or
whatever it is I always think it's kind
of funny like we all have our own
beliefs economically I'm a little more
libertarian these days but if you're
studying something within the window of
the way you want it to be it's by
default is going to be a little screwy
absolutely and as I said it is naturally
more difficult for your personal
ideological biases to come into
something that you're studying in
organic chemistry although I should
mention that there have been famous
cases where even hard sciences have been
deeply polluted by ideologies so lifes
and Co ISM y Cinco was a Russian Soviet
Union geneticist who proposed a theory
of genetics that he thought was more in
line with Marxist philosophy that was a
wrong theory of genetics that led to a
massive famine and to the death of
millions of people
so even it's not as though hard
scientists are inoculated from the
possibility of being parasitized by some
of these ideological biases do you think
it's too late for the hard sciences to
be protected like is it too late for
them to turn their forcefield on because
we do see this creeping now in biology I
mean bright white signs I'm talking
about this now but now it's really
reaching its hand into that which could
have horrific repercussions well listen
when when I when a scientist in the 21st
century I'm speaking of myself and now
has to appear in front of the Canadian
Senate to argue that there's such a
thing as male and female yeah that
evolutionary biology is based on the
recognition that there is sexual
dimorphism and human sexual dimorphism
is a fancy term for saying basically
that they are evolved sex differences
humans men veils are bigger than females
like that's a sec
by morphism so the fact that I have to
appear in front the Canadian Senate to
actually argue these things demonstrates
how far the snake has gone into the den
yeah so in a weird way your position as
a evolutionary biologist is a is sort of
right at the front of the type of person
that this ideology would attack right
just agree I'm an evolution I call a
psychotic I just said buyout yeah
although I apply evolutionary biological
program oh yes I mean it's craziness
right and and the reason why I'm so if
you like aware of the the
epidemiological dichotomy between the
natural and Social Sciences is because
my scientific career of 20-plus years
has really been straddling both these
fields like I apply evolutionary biology
to study consumer behavior consumer
behavior would be construed as something
within the social sciences evolutionary
biology is something that is within the
Natural Sciences so I really am very
much steeped in both cultures and I see
the extent to which it is easier for
people to succumb to their personal
biases and the social sciences let me
just give you one example yeah if you
start off with the premise that you
can't agree on whether there is such a
thing as innate sex differences or not
how could you from that starting point
ever build a tree of knowledge that's
organized if at this most fundamental
level we can't agree that there is such
a thing as male or female then we're
done we're cooked
physicists don't suffer from that
problem and that's why they make much
better progress than then social
scientists do so as someone that studies
marketing and why we behave how we do
what turns us on what turns us off all
of that in a weird way you were you were
prepared for everything that was going
to happen politically right now and
what's happening on the academic front
because all of these things they're all
marketing in a way Trump its marketing
Hillary market heard yourself in it in a
certain way so the trends were all their
life is marketing yeah so when people
ask you so what what do you study as as
a professor of marketing and I always
answer them everything I do in life is
marketing you market yourself on the
mating market we even use the euphemisms
of the marketplace right you know you
position yourself and the market
place you market yourself in the labor
market you market yourself to friends
you position yourself depending on
whether you wish to belong to a group or
not animals communicate with each other
right when animals advertise for example
in the peacock the peacock is literally
engaging in conspicuous advertisements
so everything in life is marketing so
one of the reasons why I was very much
interested in applying all of my
training in marketing is because that's
I think where all the sexy stuff is
right we take all of these principles
from psychology from economics from
biology and then I apply them in areas
that are of greatest import to most
people if there's something kind of
scary about that though that it's not
that the best ideas will necessarily win
it's that the best marketed ideas will
win and those often are not the same
thing very the pointless and I'm right
now working on my next book and I just
connected with a what appears to be a
wonderful literary agent and he actually
made this exact point he said look
what's really important as we move
forward your book is how to market it
because there'll be people who will be
very resistant to the ideas that you
propose in that book so again everything
is marketing so basically if you wanted
Trump do you think have not to bring
everything back in but he must have had
I guess as a businessman and putting his
name all over these things for the last
30 years
he had an innate understanding of
exactly what you're talking about
absolutely well is it I could speak to
one thing that he knew very well he
could completely read that many people
the silent majority or certainly a
sizable minority if we're going to use
the popular vote America were fed up
with political correctness and said I'm
going to be the anti PC guy and he bet
pretty much everything on that and it
turns out that people responded to it
right he could have equivocated he could
have been more careful with his words
but he sort of he flies off the handle
because he realized that the general
atmosphere was most people whether
they're having chats on Facebook or at
the workplace by the water cooler at the
University are tired of feeling stifle
are tired of feeling scared of the next
syllable that they might miss utter
that might ruin their careers and he
said I am the anti PC warrior and people
respond to that marketing position so
someone that studies all the stuff what
do you think people really drives people
at the end of the day and I mentioned
before as I say often I think it's just
a couple things you want have a job you
want have some money hopefully a house
maybe a family maybe some sex whatever
jibei the basic stuff of it all and do
you think those are really just like on
desire so in in several of my books I
actually answer that question in the
following way I map consumption act on
to four key Darwinian modules so think
about how math knows hierarchy if you
know it yeah so at the basic level
there's the physiological needs and in
belonging that your safety needs
belonging this need all the way up to
self-actualization
well his theory was really based on his
humanistic philosophy in other words he
had this bias this this ideological bias
of how humans should be it wasn't
necessarily grounded in an understanding
of biology so I took this principle and
I said no let's see what actually drives
people based on biological principles
and so by for Darwinian modules are the
survival module so a lot of things that
we do are related to our survival
instinct so our preference for fatty
foods like why is it that it's easy for
us to succumb to the desert effect
having an extra piece of desert point
we've already had more calories than we
need to well that comes from the fact
that our gustatory preferences have
evolved in an environment of corks car
city and court uncertainty so your taste
buds in mind are vestiges of an
environment long gone but that we've
evolved to have but can your brain
evolved to override that let me think
okay that's actually called the mismatch
hypothesis I'll come to in a sec okay so
first we've got survival then we've got
reproduction everything relate to sex
why do men why are 99% of Ferrari owners
male because that's the form of
peacocking so the Peacocks tail is
literally the aston martin that men
drive right yeah and of course both men
and women engage in sexual signaling so
first we've got survival instinct we've
got reproduction then we've got kin
selection kin selection is a mechanism
that explains why is it that I would
jump into the river to save three of my
brothers
if all I care about is my survivability
why would I ever take the risk on it
well when you realize that natural
selection operates at the level of the
gene then saving three brothers each of
whom share half the genes with me makes
sense now you might say well how do you
find out a consumer behavior
well gift-giving practices right so how
I'm odd you late the size of the gift
that I give to different people turns
out to be perfectly correlated to the
genetic relatedness with each of these
people I give larger gifts to my brother
than I do to my second cousin I may not
do this consciously I may not know all
these fancy theories when I'm doing it
but our brains have evolved to recognize
that people are not of equal genetic
relatedness and the fourth module is
reciprocal altruism okay I jump into the
river to save three brothers but why
would I jump in to save Dave Reuben
he's not my brother well that comes from
this evolved idea of tit for tat I
scratch your back you scratch mine well
today I might jump to save you with the
expectation that tomorrow when I'm
drowning hopefully you'll come and save
me so this idea of reciprocity has
evolved for social species and again it
explains why I will invite you out for
dinner when it's your birthday and you
will hopefully reciprocate when it's
mine from a strict economic perspective
there's no point to this right let's not
invite each other we'll be at the same
final position the reason why we do this
exchange is to oil our friendship and
our bond so I argue that much of
consumer behavior could be mapped onto
these four modules so now to your other
question know it is very difficult for
our brain to catch up to a current
reality so for example men have evolved
sexual territoriality as a as a strong
element of their psychology right they
don't like women to be promiscuous if
they're with them they get they get
sexually jealous if another man touches
their woman and so on well why would
that have evolved that goes both ways
right and women interestingly okay so
that's okay we're not a press
interested yeah this is not my voice
this is David buses work a colleague
evolution psychologist at the University
of Texas Austin he looked at with some
of his colleagues at romantic infidelity
versus sexual infidelity so he brought
in people to the lab he he set him up
with all sorts
of physiological measures to measure
their stress and have them read one of
two vignettes your your husband right
now is having sex with the gorgeous
secretary versus your husband is
developing an emotional bond with his
coworker she laughs at his jokes they
get a lot so in one case you trigger
sexual infidelity and the other one
romantic infidelity well it turns out
that women respond much more adversely
to romantic infidelity than the sexual
infidelity and that effect is reversed
for men now that doesn't mean that women
appreciate sexual infidelity or are
tolerant of it but it's less so now what
are the reasons for it well it turns out
that sexual infidelity is a profoundly
important evolutionary problem for men
because we're by parental species where
males invest a lot of their children it
doesn't make a lot of sense for me to
invest for many many years until little
Johnny grows up to be sexually mature to
then find out that it was the sexy Greek
or Roman gardener who sired that guy
right
therefore I evolved that the the
psychological apparatus to try to
protect against responsibility so I am
very intolerant of sexual infidelity if
a woman cheats on a man it almost
guarantees the end of the solution the
other way around it doesn't on the other
hand what's the greatest threat to a
woman's interest it's not that he has a
sexual dalliance one time this is why
men very naively often will say I just
had sex with her once she meant nothing
to me they actually think that this is
helping because there is no emotional
bond between us it's a one kind thing
right on the other hand if a man
develops a emotional tie with a woman
that's a much greater predictor of him
leaving the relationship and that's why
women respond so adversity to emotional
infidelity but if a man says well it was
just a one-time thing isn't he then
let's assume it's the truth for a second
guy yet does it one time he's telling
the woman what she wants to hear right I
mean what what if it's true for him it's
also what she does want to hear because
she doesn't want to hear well it's
certainly much better for him to say it
was a one-time thing rather than I think
I'm falling for her and we're planning
on having sex with another 37 times but
he's genuine honestly is trying to
convey to her that she literally meant
nothing to he's perfectly able to
decouple the sexual act from any
emotional investment right eat what you
think about when John's will go see
prostitutes what do they typically tell
you it's perfectly unencumbered sex I'm
able to have sex with her and walk away
I pay for that walking away right so
again that speaks to evolved sex
differences this whole conversation that
we've had might be transphobic systemic
violence on their bill c16 that look I
didn't talk about the non gender or
non-binary yeah I must be a genocide
supporter naturally but I'm glad you
just mentioned that because as you're
saying is I'm not even exactly sure what
my question is but is there an element
as you're sitting across from a gay
person that enters some of the great
question I don't think we finished the
mismatch question yeah okay wait let's
get to that let me first and then we'll
talk about homosexual I'm giving me a
lot here about mattis yeah that's why I
wanted to do the science that's why
we're here beautiful thank you
so our brains don't catch up as quickly
as we otherwise would want so for
example the fact that look the top
killers the top medical killers are
colon cancer heart disease diabetes from
an evolutionary medicine perspective the
argument is that it stems from the fact
that today we live in an environment of
Plenty with but our gustatory
preferences have evolved in an
environment of caloric scarcity and
uncertainty that mismatch between our
current environment of Plenty and the
environment in which we've evolved
causes some of these top killers so to
answer your question in a long-winded
way no our brains don't catch up if
there were selection pressures for the
next X number of years to cause an
evolutionary trajectory to change that
it would happen but typically for even
the most basic genetic selection
it might take say 5,000 years right so I
guess what I'm talking about then is for
the person that never goes to the desert
or never engines this or that that's not
an evolutionary thing as much as it's
someone that's aware
it's someone that's educated and aware
of that these things can cause health
problems and you might be like I live
here in LA where everyone doesn't eat
this or that or doesn't want gluten
everyone's everyone has celiac disease
which no one has celiac disease I mean
so that's not evolution that's just sort
of doing something different with the
information you have right it's not on
the macro level and evolutionary well
and sometimes you have multiple
Darwinian poles pulling you in different
directions so that the net effect is
zero so for example when I explained why
there are evolutionary pressures for
both men and women to cheat on their
long-term partners that doesn't mean
that it's a fatalistic argument it's not
biological determinism we're doomed to
cheat because we also have evolved the
moral calculus right our morality unless
you're a religious person that thinks
that it comes from God our morality has
also evolved through the exact same
evolutionary forces that explain why we
have opposable thumbs and so on the one
hand I'd like to very much cheat on my
wife on the other hand I've got this
moral catalyst that stops you from doing
the net effect is that I might actually
not do it so this speaks to a really
important point which is the fact that
you explain something from an
evolutionary perspective doesn't mean
that it is biologically fatalistic got
it all right so how much sexual ah yes
now if we add that into this mix that
you're talking about here so the the
taught theory that has been proposed
that has not the data has not cooperated
comes from actually kin selection so let
me explain it's a bit technical yeah so
you could increase your fitness in other
words you could you could extend your
genes through direct reproduction that's
called direct Fitness right if I have
children I'm extending my genes but I
could also if you like increase my
inclusive fitness by investing in those
who are related to me when I when I
invest in my nephews I am indirectly
extending my genes correct
so the argument then is that that
homosexuality need not be a Darwinian to
the stock meaning a Darwinian dead end
because even though you may decide to
not have children by investing in your
kin
you could still be extending your
how would you test this idea well you
would take for example homosexual uncles
and heterosexual uncles and see if the
homosexual uncle's invest more in their
nephews and nieces and if the answer
would be yes then that would be one data
point that supports the idea I have
taught my nephew everything I know about
Star Wars and I am very bad importunate
your nose every year right yeah but the
data have not supported that so the
bottom line is the top argument the top
ever lose weight the data has not
supported but that actually happened
exactly not only the kins
the kin selection based argument for
homosexuality while at the theoretical
level conceptually speaking is good yeah
the data has not supported that so
that's as far as I know about the nexus
between homosexuality and evolution
although I think we might have mentioned
this one you came on my show I do have a
current doctoral student who is actually
planning on studying in his doctoral
dissertation the intersection between
now get ready for this homosexuality
evolutionary psychology and consumer
behavior how is that going to work so
we're going to look at phenomena that
typically happen between men and women
and for example if you go out on a first
date the best way to never have a second
date and the heterosexual context is for
a man to be cheap on a first date right
that's guarantee and even if the woman
is a billionaire if he exhibits cues of
frugality it's dead yeah okay so then
let's take this idea and see whether
within the context of the dynamics of
homosexual relationship when it when two
men go out on a date for the first time
could we see a replication of this
phenomenon but now there isn't
male/female here so what would be the
proxy measure pop bottom yeah so could
for example your sexual as either a
predominantly top or predominantly
bottom replicate the sex differences
that we typically see at the
interactions between men and women what
do you really think of that by the way
well I don't know that it's so
interesting because I don't know that
your sexual position has anything to do
with how you necessarily on a date would
say I'm going to pay or not pay I don't
I get where I get this you're saying
that basically the the top is all I
think the
villain right I guess I mean I guess
it's only that's what I would have
guessed did I not say that but I don't
know that there's a we're going to test
some it let's take another example of
exactly this idea so when when men and
women mate there's what's called a sort
of mating so birds of a feather flock
together
so typically women it's not that women
want necessarily tall guys is that they
want a taller guy so it just it's very
rare for a woman to date someone shorter
than her so there's actually a study
that was done with 720
naturally-occurring couples only one of
the 720 was the woman taller the demand
really yeah it's a quite extraordinary
rare so let's now let's apply that to
almost now I haven't done the research
but here's my hypothesis yeah I bet that
the top bottom distinction will
determine the height thing in other
words if the the bottom guy will be in a
long-term Union in a matter meeting in
the gay sauna for xx yeah long term
period and met you know a marriage he'll
be the shorter guy so a lot of the
phenomena that we would pick up from
evolutionary psychology as applied to
heterosexual context will replicate in
the homosexual context so I'm curious
all this being said as you said you're
hypothesizing about some of this stuff
and and obviously your your students
going to work on some of this in other
people organism is is there a
complication that links everything else
we've been talking about where if you
talk about gay anything that this could
get you in some sort of trouble I don't
sense you feel that as you're talking
about it but that there would be some
piece of this that you might find
something that would lead you to
somewhere uncomfortable or something if
the context of academia yeah I don't
need you person lack of love but I
actually think that if you do any
research right now on any of the LGBTQ
things that would be a very good thing
because it would be somehow labeled as a
progressive so in the context of the e
unless that you came to a conclusion
already that was not politically correct
yeah yes so that speaks to actually an
issue that I've discussed with several
folks and I think perhaps maybe sam
Harris mentioned that when he had me on
this show he was asking me is there any
research that you would get and I want
to care for you this very thing okay so
maybe we can get into that at and the
the term that I had used with him then
which came from a
papers published in nature forbidden
knowledge no I am a strong non proponent
of the idea forbidden knowledge if
research is done honestly assiduously
with full adherence to the scientific
method then there is no question that is
too taboo to to ask that actually speaks
to something in philosophy the
difference between deontological ethics
and consequentialist ethics the in
pelagic Aleph X is the following it is
never okay to lie
that's a bientot logical statement a
consequentialist ethics statement would
say well it might be okay to lie
depending on the consequences of the lie
right right if it's going to cause 20
people to die exactly so one is an
absolutist perspective one is it's a
situation on depends on the consequences
so I will use that framework to answer
the the forbidden taboo question of what
kind of research is okay or not yeah if
you are a purist at the ontological
epistemological person I do research
wherever it takes me
then you don't care about the
consequences if you are consequentialist
bent then you say well but if we do race
differences and the results come out in
a way that it could be used to harm a
racial group then we should stay away
from it I actually think that that's a
profoundly dangerous position to take
because it's precisely this type of
argument that led the Social Sciences to
reject biology as being important the
the early anthropologist cultural
anthropologist who said biology doesn't
matter for humans we're coming from an
honorable place because they saw how
cretins could misuse biology like the
Nazis can say hey there's a battle
between the races as a Darwinian
struggle
we're Aryan we won who cares and let the
Jews die the British social cost elite
has said there's a battle between the
social classes the lower classes lost
screw them it's a Darwinian struggle of
course this has nothing to do with
Darwin but because these folks
misappropriate misappropriated
biological thinking then the cultural
anthropologist came along and said let's
get rid of biology because then nobody
can misuse it and now we're in the
quagmire where we are
a where we have to appear in front of
the Canadian Senate to argue that there
is such a thing as male or female so
know if you are a purist you pursue
knowledge wherever it takes you
unencumbered by the consequences is the
problem that I suppose a certain amount
of people scientists included probably
think that their purest but actually
aren't you know it I mean like so so
Mengele probably thought that you know
who is doing all sorts of you might all
not be on yeah I we're not yeah in this
particular case I feel a Nazi references
out it is actually sensible as opposed
to Nazi references that are thrown
around all day long but but if you think
about that I mean Mengele was doing
horrific experiments on on twins and
just all sorts of things that were
considered beyond imagination horrible
probably believed that he was doing it
for the good of truth and the good of
science and all that I don't you know to
be a lie sure Friday he may have been a
horrific person I don't think he in his
heart he probably thought he was doing
good though so the only thing that I
would say that would stop that from
happening now is that we do have
institutional review boards or ethics
boards now that ensure that there is a
boundary on the scientific pursuits that
you could well pursue that and that is
you know you can't frivolously harm
animals the way you treat them in the
lab is important you can't frivolously
harm both physically and or
psychologically human subjects right but
answers interestingly though now they've
gone overboard so the institutional
review boards now have become so aware
to want to be the antithesis of Mendeley
so that now if i ask you what is your
set that's right so that could be
traumatizing if i ask you what is your
income well weight in some cultures
that's an affront and that could send
the person into a tailspin of suicide
because i asked what his income is and
so now the most banal innocuous
questions has to be discussed for
seventy three thousand years and these
institutional review boards so I think
the fulcrum nice one too far the other
way so that it is now stopping good
science from being done
because we are so afraid of harming any
third party so the good intention of we
actually don't
harm this animal or we don't want to
inject a dye into a human's item I blind
them has become now we don't want to
offend this person exactly right this is
a huge jump that dangerous reside
absolutely and frankly I see the fear in
my graduate students when they're about
to apply for a thesis grant because
they've heard all these horror stories
that they come to me as a professor sad
how long is the process going to take
and I always answer them it really
depends on the makeup of the folks that
are going to review your application if
they are perfectly reasonable people it
might go through in a session if they
are absolute maniacs it might take us
three months of rewriting this damn
thing for some guy to finally accept
that you know we're not injecting dye in
people's face and the reality is most of
the research that I get involved in all
those you know very rigorous and
scientific really has no downstream harm
that's going to be caused
but it's unbelievable the types of
concerns that people raise and and we
need to rail that rain that in a bit
yeah I wanna talk a little bit about
robotics which I've never even mentioned
the phrase robot to you or any of that
stuff but there is something about we're
getting into this time with incredible
automation and we know about you know
cars that are driving themselves and we
know that you know people iPads are
going to put McDonald's employees out of
business and all of this stuff how will
that affect the way we evolve
how'd it like now that we're going to
add this thing that is completely
artificial and outside of us is there an
evolutionary piece to that or is that
something else altogether I think it's
something because for evolution to to
work right there there has to be a
selection environment that is if I'm
bored let me for your viewers who may
not know how evolution works like I'll
explain it three seconds okay let you a
male and a female get together through
sexual reproduction they have an
offspring this random combination and
shuffling of genes results in their
offspring having a blue dot here if that
blue dot is heritable it could be passed
on and if that blue dot confers a
survival advantage to the animal then
the selection pressures are in place for
eventually that blue dot to become part
of the makeup of that species so to
answer your question you would have to
explain to me how there are specific
selection pressures that affect the
survivability of an organism or its
reproductive viability for me to be able
to offer an evolution argument right now
I can't take it one because I'm here
that does make sense I feel I can't end
this on a question that we would say
doesn't make sense perfectly so I will
ask you this and we're going to do this
many more times you'll do this again any
time I'm here all right
taking everything we've discussed here
are you hopeful or not for the future of
the West do you think we are just caught
in sort of this leftist postmodernist
stuff versus a national ism or a
populism that could be dangerous or do
you think that the Enlightenment values
that you care about in liberalism and
all that actually has a chance to turn
this stuff so here's now where I need to
put on my marketing hat oh yeah as in
sell it brother exactly so if I'm going
to speak about some of the times when I
see the tsunami of ostrich thinking that
comes my way and I feel very pessimistic
I feel as though an utter disaster has
to happen before people wake up on the
other hand because I'd like to have the
hope and market hope I think that it
doesn't take too much to redress the
ship if enough silent people silent
voices rise up in every ecosystem on
Facebook on them in the media in
academia at the bar and actually the you
know trigger the courage that is
necessary for them to weigh in I think
that the voices the enemies of reason
will become marginalized but we need to
rise up and that's why I always tell
people when they ask me well what can I
do
I said well you don't have to have the
voice of Dave Rubin or the platform of
Dave Lewin you just have to have enough
courage to take on your friends when
you're engaging them on Facebook when
your professor says something that seems
like it's an affront to Reason challenge
him or her don't be silent so I think
that if enough people do that then the
ship can be addressed if we remain
apathetic then I think we will lose yeah
I totally agree and as I always say I'm
one
started a channel on YouTube your one
guy who started a channel on YouTube we
came for very different places and and
if our voices have done a little
something then there's plenty of other
people that can replicate and brother as
well all right I think you guys know
where his channel is but if not check
out dad's YouTube channel at youtube.com
slash get set
[Music]
you